Cramer's rule is you're going to
calculate the determinant okay of okay
let me see if I can show you this here
I'll try to draw this out like so okay
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to take the coefficients okay of
the variables here we're going to make
it into a matrix okay so we've got 1 1
and 1 so 1 1 1 2 negative 1 3 2 negative
1 3 3 2 & 1 3 2 & 1 so that's going to
compose our denominator of x y&z okay so
it's going to be the same matrix here
okay using the coefficients 1 1 1 2
negative 1 3 & 3 2 1 okay now for we do
the numerator
okay the matrix that we're going to use
is we're going to use these same
coefficients but when we're solving for
X we're going to replace the X
coefficients with the solutions so I'm
going to put 6 4 and 13 but then I'm
going to put the remaining numbers here
in the second and third column okay so
with me so far so all I did is I replace
the X coefficients with the solutions
with y I'm gonna replace the Y
coefficients with the solutions so 6 4
and 13 and with Z I'm gonna replace the
Z coefficients with the solutions and
then I'm just going to go back in you
can see I'm putting the coefficients
back in here 1 3 & 1 and let's see here
this is going to be 1 2 3 & 1 negative 1
2
all right so we've got it all set up now
at this point when you see these you
know bars like that that means take the
determinant usually have a matrix you'll
have like little bracket okay but when
you take the determinant of a 3 by 3
matrix there's a couple different ways
to do it I'm going to show you an easy
way to do it an easy way to remember it
and what you do is you just take the
matrix and you write it right next to
the original matrix so I'm just going to
copy this down 1 1 1 2 negative 1 3 3 2
1 now what we're going to do is we're
going to multiply in the diagonal like
so so these guys multiplied together
plus these guys multiplied together okay
plus these guys multiply together so the
ones going on the diagonal from this
corner down to the right so let's do
that so that's going to be negative one
plus nine plus four okay - we're going
to multiply the diagonals going up to
the right so this is going to be 3 times
negative 1 times 1 which is negative 3 2
times 3 times 1 which is 6 and 1 times 2
times 1 which is 2 so if we simplify
that down we get 13 minus 1 is 12 okay
and this is 8 minus 3 which is 5 and 12
minus 5 is 7 so because the denominator
is 4 all three of these x y&z these
determinants are exactly the same we
know that the denominator is going to be
7 7 & 7 are you with me so far we're
gonna do the same thing with the
determinant here we're going to copy the
first you're gonna copy the matrix right
next to the original matrix okay so
that's what I'm doing here I'm just
copying the matrix side by side and I'm
going to do the same process I'm going
to be multiplying on the diagonal so
that gives us negative 6 plus 1 times 3
times 13 which is 39 plus 1 times 4
times 2 which is 8 okay so that comes
out to what let's see if we can we'll do
that we'll do the other diagonal so
going up to the right now that's going
to give us negative 13 negative 13 2
times 3 times 6 gives us 36 so notice
how we're adding those together and then
1 times 4 times 1 which gives us 4 so
that's 40 minus 13 which is 27 okay over
here we have what this is 47 minus 6
which is 41 in 41 minus 27 this 14 and
14 divided by 7 is 2 okay so that's it
so you got it and you would repeat the
same process for y and z and then what
you can do once you get your answer I'll
tell you the answer for this one if you
want to solve it it should be 2/3 and 1
and you can check by putting it back in
2 plus 3 plus 1 is 6 you know put 2 3 &
1 you should get 4 2 3 & 1 you should
get 13